alguna vez os habéis preguntado cómo se
puede secuestrar un país cómo se pueden
someter pervertir y corromper las
instituciones y tal vez la pregunta más
importante de todas cómo identificar el
momento en el que una democracia tras
ser secuestrada deja de funcionar amigos
durante años éstas han sido preguntas
que han condicionado la política
internacional pero sobre todo la
política de américa latina nuestra
generación vive una crisis de identidad
se manifiesta en un permanente
cuestionamiento de los valores
tradicionales de nuestra cultura y
asumen en muchos casos las
construcciones nihilistas de la
subversión antinacional ésta nunca ha
sido dictaduras está blanda pero si es
necesario vamos a tener que apretar la
mano porque tenemos que salvar primero
el país y después miraremos de atrás
[Música]
durante las últimas décadas han sido
numerosos los caudillos latinoamericanos
que han tomado el control de sus países
en ocasiones lo hicieron mediante golpes
de estado pero en otras muchas ocasiones
estos caudillos llegaron al poder por
vías democráticas este es precisamente
el caso del presidente de nicaragua
daniel ortega
[Música]
amigos aquí en visual político ya os
hemos hablado de este personaje político
de cómo llegó al poder cómo se comportó
y de cómo ha sido el responsable de las
enormes protestas que ve nicaragua en
[Música]
a través
unas protestas que han sido respondidas
con mano dura y están dejando un saldo
atroz más de 200 personas han perdido la
vida los detenidos se encuentran por
cientos y los heridos por miles pues
bien en este vídeo nos vamos a fijar en
otra faceta de los acontecimientos esta
es la historia de cómo un gobierno
consiguió hacerse con el control total
del estado y poner a las instituciones a
trabajar no para el país sino para el
mismo esta es la historia de como una
especie de mafia política se hizo con
las riendas de nicaragua atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
año 2006 daniel ortega gana las
elecciones presidenciales de nicaragua
tras 16 años en la oposición el líder
sandinista regresaba a la presidencia
del país los precedentes no eran
precisamente buenos su primera etapa
como presidente entre 1985 y 1990 fue
terrible ortega dejó un país económica y
socialmente destrozado
[Música]
un país que de facto estuvo en guerra
que terminó con una deuda externa seis
veces más grande que su pib de una
hiperinflación que tan solo en 1987
alcanzó la astronómica cifra del 33 mil
547 por ciento para que os hagáis una
idea de la magnitud del desastre en 1990
la renta per cápita de nicaragua era un
55 un 55% más pequeña que la que el país
había registrado en 1978 en otras
palabras comparándose con daniel ortega
hasta los kirchner sacarían buena nota
amigos el modelo económico de ortega fue
un rotundo fracaso las expropiaciones la
gigantesca deuda exterior la imparable
impresión de dinero y su obsesión por el
control total de la economía condujeron
a nicaragua una situación insostenible
como para no menuda receta
[Música]
y si a todo esto le sumamos el conflicto
con las contras financiadas por eeuu el
desastre para el país fue ya total
porque lo de todos
[Música]
por cierto apunte las contras fueron
grupos paramilitares financiados por
washington mediante la venta de armas a
irán cuando este país se encontraba en
plena guerra con irak un país que
supuestamente era cercano a washington
en definitiva un despropósito el caso es
que durante la siguiente década el país
sólo tuvo una misión recuperarse de todo
este desastre
[Música]
a ver nicaragua sin libertad
son de ser de nicaragua es la libertad
[Música]
para ello los siguientes gobiernos
empezando por el de violeta chamorro por
cierto la primera presidenta en américa
latina' elegida mediante las urnas
apostaron por dar un giro de 180 grados
al planteamiento político y económico
del país es decir pasar de una economía
centralizada organizada y dirigida por
el estado a una economía de mercado
así es como nacieron las zonas francas
de nicaragua y las políticas de
atracción de inversión extranjera lo que
unido a la cooperación internacional y
sobre todo a las crecientes remesas
procedentes del extranjero permitieron
que nicaragua comenzará a ponerse de
nuevo en marcha
ahora
[Música]
[Aplausos]
sin embargo espera un momento porque lo
que no consiguieron estos nuevos
gobiernos fue terminar con la corrupción
así escándalo tras escándalo la
sensación de frustración decepción y
engaño que sintieron los nicaragüenses
junto a una oposición que estaba
dispuesta a casi todo con tal de
regresar al poder
alimentaron la victoria de ortega en
[Música]
y aquí amigos a partir de este momento
comienza una nueva historia entre otras
cosas porque ortega tenía claro que no
iba a desaprovechar su regreso al poder
esta era su ocasión su oportunidad para
dominar la política las finanzas y la
sociedad nicaragüense pero para lograrlo
y sobre todo para impedir que un proceso
electoral le volviera a desalojar de la
presidencia necesitaba hacerse con el
poder político con el monopolio de la
fuerza y también con el poder económico
esta es amigos la estrategia que puso en
marcha y los pasos que dio para alcanzar
su propósito atento
[Música]
el poder político
evidentemente la primera meta en toda
esta estrategia pasa por lograr la
hegemonía política y el control social
por cualquier medio esto ortega lo tuvo
muy claro desde el principio y para ello
puso en marcha una doble táctica
por un lado invadir las instituciones y
centralizar el poder por otro limitar y
amedrentar a la oposición algo para lo
que el miedo suele ser un ingrediente
muy pero que muy eficaz de esta forma al
poco de llegar al poder
ortega puso en marcha una fuerza
paramilitar compuesta por pandilleros
hablamos de los grupos de choque más
conocidos en nicaragua como las turbas
son de temer y la población los llama
turbas suelen vestir camisetas con
leyendas que hablan de amor y paz usan
cascos para ocultar sus rostros y se
movilizan en motos en su mayoría son
jóvenes jóvenes violentos
matilde córdoba periodistas en managua
su objetivo amedrentar a la oposición
política atemorizar a quienes discrepan
del gobierno y tratar de reventar
reventar mediante la violencia las
manifestaciones o concentraciones de la
oposición evidentemente no es una fuerza
oficial pero cuentan con la protección
del gobierno en un momento veremos cómo
podemos decir que en nicaragua se ha
constituido una fuerza paramilitar que
está compuesta por pandilla
a veces nos subimos a un bus y está un
paramilitar observándonos heidi castillo
activista nicaragüense pero por supuesto
aquí no termina todo el siguiente paso
para lograr un poder político total es
hacerse precisamente con el control de
las instituciones del estado ahora bien
como pensáis que lo hizo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pues lo primero de todo fue poner fin a
la descentralización política en este
caso a la autonomía municipal
de esta forma en nicaragua los secuaces
políticos de ortega han llegado a
destituir a alcaldes a su complacencia
algo así como oye si tienes un rival
político échale de la carrera es una
forma no sólo de eliminar adversarios
también de ganar fieles que claro no
quieren correr riesgos
lo segundo crear y dar legitimidad a sus
propias organizaciones políticas en este
caso los consejos del poder ciudadano
unos órganos supuestamente de
participación comunitaria pero que en la
práctica tienen el objetivo de crear una
estructura política paralela reconocida
y controlada por el gobierno
y lo tercero nombrar y lograr la
permanencia indefinida de sus allegados
de partido en todos los puestos claves
del estado el poder electoral el poder
judicial y la contraloría general y si
un funcionario protesta pues para eso
están las turbas no queréis dos pruebas
de lo que consiguió ortega con toda esta
estrategia fijaos
[Música]
la constitución de nicaragua prohibía la
reelección consecutiva de un presidente
de esta forma ortega hubiera concluido
su mandato en 2011 sin embargo tal y
como hizo hernández en honduras
ortega consiguió que la sala
constitucional del tribunal supremo
compuesta en su mayoría por magistrados
sandinistas declarar inaplicable el
artículo 147 que es el que impedía la
reelección consecutiva del presidente a
cambio eso si los magistrados lograron
su permanencia vitalicia en el cargo
desde luego no parece mala recompensa
por otro lado en las elecciones de 2011
las sospechas de fraude fueron tan
intensas que tanto la unión europea como
la organización de estados americanos
concluyeron que no tenían certeza de los
resultados sabéis quién controlaba el
poder electoral exacto ortega se había
asegurado de que sus adeptos pudieran
hacer y deshacer a su antojo de hecho en
las siguientes elecciones en las de 2016
ya ni se cortaron y el oficialismo se
hizo con el control total del proceso
pero un momento puede que estéis
pensando pero enrique no hubo acaso
algún gran escándalo bueno digamos que
el presidente se había encargado de que
prácticamente todos los grandes medios
de comunicación del país estuvieran
controlados por su familia o por socios
suyos la familia ortega monopoliza los
medios de comunicación en nicaragua
turbas ocupación de las instituciones y
medios de comunicación esta es la parte
política pero aún hay más
[Música]
el monopolio de la fuerza claro por
mucho que tenga el poder político si un
caudillo no controla la fuerza asume un
riesgo enorme nuestro protagonista esto
lo tenía clarísimo así que el segundo
pilar en toda esta estrategia fue tomar
las riendas de la policía y del ejército
para ello aprovechando su mayoría en la
asamblea nacional
ortega sacó adelante nada más llegar al
poder o una reforma que concentró en sus
manos nuevas facultades como jefe
supremo de la policía nacional y del
ejército de la república luego
aprovechándose de estas nuevas
posibilidades puso a familiares y leales
directamente al mando de estas
instituciones por ejemplo la policía
está dirigida de facto por su propio con
suegro francisco díaz de tal manera que
ante las turbas la policía bueno mira
para otro lado y ante las
manifestaciones de la oposición la
represión de represión y represión
y es que amigos cuando la magia se hace
con el poder no esperes que lo suelte
fácilmente pero política fuerza pública
nos falta un tercer elemento
capitalina es algo
el poder económico
el tercer pilar en toda esta estrategia
fue lograr el poder económico por tres
razones primero para evitar que el
capital nicaragüense apoyara otra
alternativa segundo para lograr recursos
con los que llevar a cabo sus planes y
tercero tal vez el punto más importante
para forrarse para llenarse el bolsillo
durante este tiempo amigos la corrupción
ha sido brutal hasta tal punto que hoy
la familia ortega murillo es millonaria
millonaria de verdad fijaos han tomado
el control de medios de comunicación han
ocupado altos cargos del estado se han
adjudicado la importación y distribución
de petróleo nicaragua se han puesto al
frente de las agencias de promoción de
inversión con un plan que podríamos
describir en esta línea quieres invertir
en nicaragua estupendo te damos
facilidades pero a mí me das una
comisión ya sabéis todo por la patria
también han llegado a acuerdos con
empresarios
aparentemente lealtad y sobres a cambio
de privilegios
un caso claro de esta forma de hacer las
cosas fue el acuerdo para construir el
canal interoceánico un proyecto
aparentemente fallido pero en el que el
gobierno llegó a un acuerdo bajo la mesa
con one game el empresario chino
promotor de la obra al principio el
estado se reservaba la mitad de los
beneficios al final con un cambio de
última hora el 1%
se ve que el empresario supo regatear en
el último momento que capacidad ni messi
es capaz de regatear así en fin amigos
el caso es que con el poder político con
la fuerza y con el poder económico
daniel ortega se hizo dueño y señor de
nicaragua y bueno parece que
multimillonario también y por si las
moscas en las últimas elecciones en las
de 2016 presentó como vicepresidenta a
rosario murillo su mujer así todo queda
en casa
amigos todo el proceso que hemos visto
en cierta forma es muy similar a lo
acontecido en venezuela y es que es por
así decirlo el manual de todo caudillo y
la pregunta que podemos hacernos es
realmente podemos pretender pensar que
nicaragua sigue siendo una democracia
déjame tu opinión en los comentarios y
como siempre si te ha resultado
interesante el vídeo dale a like y no
olvides suscribirte a visual político si
aún no lo has hecho por cierto muchas
gracias a nuestro amigo
irvine cordero abogado y escritor
nicaragüense por la ayuda que nos ha
prestado en la conformación de este
vídeo un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Aplausos]